I'm part of a team that's trying to
re-re repeat the golden record
experiment we're trying to create like
an open source version of the golden
record the future spacecraft are able to
download and basically put a lot of hard
drive that they can carry around with
them and you know get these distributed
hopefully across the solar system
eventually and it's going to be called
The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
yeah it could be that's a good name for
it we've we've been talking a little bit
with the name but I think probably just
be golden record at this point I've got
record version two or something but
um I think uh I think another benefit
that I see of this activity
is that it forces us as a species
to ask those questions about what it is
that we want under the civilization to
know about us the god record was kind of
funny because it had photos on it and it
had photos of people eating for instance
um but it had no photos of people
defecating and so I always thought that
was kind of funny because of her post if
I was an alien yeah or if I was studying
an alien if I saw images of an alien I
wouldn't I'm not trying to be like a
perv or anything but I would want to see
the full by I wanted to sign the biology
of that alien and so we we always censor
what we what we show
um and which we should show the whole
actual natural process and then also say
we humans tend to censor these things we
tend to not like to walk around naked we
tend to not to talk about uh some of the
natural biological phenomena and talk a
lot about others yeah and and actually
just be very uh like the way you would
be to a therapist or something very
transparent about the way we actually
operate yeah I mean and Sagan had that
has second had that with the golden
record I think he he originally uh
there's a there's a male and a female
figure depicts on the golden record and
the the woman had a genitalia originally
drawn and uh there was a lot of pushback
from I think a lot of Christian groups
who were not happy about the idea of
throwing this into space And So
eventually they had to remove that and
so it would be confusing biologically if
you're you know trying to study
xenobiology of this alien that
apparently has no genitalia or demanders
but for some reason the woman doesn't
you know and that's our that's our own
uh societal and cultural uh imprint
happening into that information that's
to be fair
just even having
two Sexes and predators and prey just a
whole that could be just a very unique
Earth-like thing so they might be
confused about why there's like pairs of
things like why are you like why why is
there a man and a woman in general like
they they could be I mean they could be
confused about a lot of things in
general I don't think the I don't even
know which way to hold the pizza
or there's the picture they don't they
might not need they they might have very
different sensory devices to even
interpret this if they only you know
have uh sound is our only way of
navigating the world it's kind of lost
to send any kind of you know there's
been a lot of conversation about sending
video and uh audio and uh video and
pictures and I've that's one of the
things I've been a little bit resistant
about in the team that I've been
thinking well they might have eyes and
so if you lived in um on the Europa
surface having eyes wouldn't be very
useful
um if you lived in a on a very dark
planet on the tightly locked night side
of an exoplanet having eyes would be
particularly useful so it's kind of a
presumption of us to think that video is
a useful form of communication